Brit should take the travel advice that
we have issued we've updated it this
morning they should take that travel
advice and we will do everything we can
to help them so that is hiding under the
bed until a ceasefire well as I say that
we will do everything we possibly can to
help them in every way we can and in the
meanwhile where possible they should
stay indoors and wait but you can't do
anything until it sees fire from what
you say well we will do everything we
can including uh before a ceasefire if
we can successfully do it but let me
make this point yesterday the Turks
organized a convoy they had three muster
points where they were encouraging their
people to come to two of those Master
points were shot up during the time they
were assembling this is incredibly
dangerous we have to be very careful
what advice
um civilian time
indeed the Germans are coming in after
the French and after us and they are
moving uh some of their people but I
should emphasize that the number of
Germans who are there is very very much
smaller than the number of Brits